NULEI!
We are Gen Z to come, EXE!
Show the world that we want it Sing out!
Show nothing can stop it Break out!
Break the cycle of fate we're pushing through Break out!
Turn our eyes to the future Cause we're stronger than ever
Break out!
Headlight's mightier than the sword Fighting on Burning like
a sun as it sets upon the town I love The heart is set
aflame by a coal from all above The princess, we take a key
bar Protecting what a sacred require, sacrifice The
princess, we take a key bar Side by side until the end of
the earth Take up the fight The night may fall as misty
sadness blooms from our eyes And in half we'll stand
together with you by your side Standing tall as three with
the strength from inside The spirit of the misfit of me is
yours for us We let you down We'll pave the way through all
the hate My love from daji, kentuma narake Our passion hide
in everyone With voices ringing out all over the world Let
go of the head past all the dread And
one day near we see We'll become our new heroine And even
I'll fight for you For all of that cool I feel burning on
Shout out!
Show the world that we wanted Sing out!
Show up nothing can stop it Break up!
Break the cycle of faith we're pushing through Break up!
Turn our eyes to the future Cause we're stronger than the
sword Fighting on A battle's never lost if there's still
fire in my soul There's sense, they think real good now
Kindle it with hope, let it rise, pierce the cold There's
sense, they do the punch, punch What's another round bar in
a long-dying flame?
It would be the secret of love Now we're fading out in front
of the crowd Lighting away
Blooming against from the planet When we're trying to shake
up You'll get a prize through the winter And all the heat
and rain are in the mist And all the seasons change We're
rooted to my dreams We're wearing the storm Let's go I'm
driving rise in the towns Gonna be reviving Akiypa Gotta
create a ko no ikigai I'm not gonna die This wave I'm
riding, turning pain to power Tengoku, a mama roll, Kaiju,
what does it go?
All these monsters laughing They don't know Listen, listen,
listen
I've always known I'm not alone But now I truly do believe
in my soul This time I swore I'll stand once more What once
was broken has now become old Our voices loud, one with the
crowd They shake us up, but we'll never go down So stand
your ground and sing it proud Our battle cry is ringing out
through the dark
We'll pave the way through all the hate My love from magic
and the monadaké Our passion lies in every word With voices
ringing out all over the world Let's look ahead
The NPC will become our new heroine I'll fight for you For
all of the crew Still one of you
Show the world that we wanted Show the world that we wanted
Show the world
that's mighty, then let's go